we're now only six days away from
Apple's huge wonderlust iPhone 15 event
and while everybody basically already
knows what to expect due to all the
recent leaks Apple's been working on a
huge secret accessory that essentially
no one has been expecting and I
guarantee there will be a lot of upset
people due to this change but don't
worry there's also some good news
because for once Apple's gonna be mixing
it up and pushing something even harder
than they ever have before with the new
product and that's being environmentally
friendly which is cool and all but it
usually means something nice has to go
away and yes I'm sorry to say that
Apple's beloved super high quality
leather iPhone cases are going away for
good and not only that but there's a
good chance that their genuine leather
Apple watch bands are gonna disappear as
well in the name of the environment and
to take it step further Apple's busting
out 3D printers for the first time but
before I explain that let me get into
the Innovative brand new secret
accessory that's been in the works at
Apple welcome the new fine woven Case by
Apple for the iPhone 15 lineup yes this
is Apple's apparent replacement for
their genuine leather cases which is
supposed to be super premium now I don't
know if apple is going to be introducing
synthetic leather cases that actually
look and feel like leather but these
ones right here are gonna be super
unique these leaks come from Imagine
Boot and other sources on Twitter and
they've been confirmed by reliable
sources like Mark German who shared a
video from Sony Dixon showing off this
cool new material which actually looks
quite nice it's apparently going to be
made from a fabric material and
Technology named fine woven twill which
is what the official leaked name find
woven will come from and it's a type of
textile weaving characterized by a
diagonal stripe so it'll basically feel
like fabric but also really premium as
you can see the back portion is raised
and it almost looks like a slab of
material sewed onto the sides which are
also fine woven and look quite nice with
plastic buttons for that clicky feel I
also think this is the perfect time and
opportunity to release this case because
apple is also going to start giving us
braided USBC cables so what if the
material used in both the cable and the
case is the same and come to think of it
these new cases really remind me of
Samsung's and Google's fabric cases that
were also quite nice and of course the
main reason for all of this is that
Apple can say that they used recycled
materials and completely gotten rid of
real leather so they can boast about
their environmentally friendly
accomplishments but get getting back to
the Fine woven case there are going to
be a ton of different colors and the
fabric might be woven so tightly that it
could even feel like Apple's polishing
cloth which is super soft looking at
this photo shared by Hartley Charlton it
looks so fine and smooth that it also
looks like suede that's sometimes used
in car Interiors which is a very nice
and high quality material however you do
want to take caution that this material
isn't that water resistant according to
Majin Buu's sources and it could
potentially be ruined by water so if
that's an issue or concern for you you
should probably skip this and go with
something else now the only problem is
that according to Majin Buu these cases
will apparently cost around 100
which is insane for a case in my opinion
and I would rather have genuine leather
but that's just me so it looks like many
people will be looking for real leather
Alternatives and if that's you Nomad
makes a really good genuine leather case
now because of those options I don't
think this will be a very big deal
however what I think is a big deal is
that according to Mark gurman Apple's
gonna start moving away from genuine
leather on their Apple watch bands as
well so I wonder if they'll come out
with a new fine woven watch band made
out of fabric but being so fine that it
feels soft like leather kasutami song on
Twitter actually leaked something like
this last month saying that apple is
going to be coming out with a new
magnetic band option which would be made
out of woven fabric material which
sounds like it would match the fine
woven cases perfectly so it's awesome
that all of these leaks are coming
together and matching up but getting
even more interesting Mark German said
that last month Apple started offering
employees its Hermes leather accessories
and leather link bands at up to 90
percent off which is insane with apple
basically trying to clear their
inventory he gave some extra contacts by
mentioning that an apple or mess band
normally 850 is on sale for only 85 for
Apple employees so this hints at a
chance that Apple might completely ditch
all genuine leather materials for good
at this event in the name of the
environment Mark basically believes that
between the move away from leather on
the Apple watch bands and cases Apple's
gonna really focus on environment and
sustainability at this September 12th
event including the new use of 3D
printers for the first time ever to
actually 3D print different parts of the
Apple Watch series 9 itself so basically
with all that said Apple's gonna do what
they're gonna do and I think that the
new fine woven case will be great but
it's sad to see them start to ditch
their leather cases and especially watch
bands the good news is that you'll
always be able to find third party
genuine leather options if you really
care about that now moving on to some
other wonderlust event related leaks and
rumors we've been seeing more and more
discussion about Apple's iPhone 15 Pro
Max model actually being renamed the
ultra this year instead of waiting until
next year the crazy thing is that we're
not expecting very many changes on this
model other than the Periscope camera
being exclusive but we might actually
get some other features like eight gigs
of RAM instead of six on the regular pro
model and a thunderbolt port instead of
USBC and maybe even some other exclusive
features but I believe that the main
reason Apple would do this this year is
because they really want to boost their
sales and the best way to do that is to
change the name or The Branding which
worked wonders with the very first pro
model in the iPhone 11 lineup everyone
just wanted the pro name associated with
their phone and maybe Apple has realized
that Samsung already has an ultra
branded phone so they need to match it
to make it seem on the same level
especially since Apple already has an M2
Pro chipped for their Max and an M2
Ultra chip which is the best now going
further with the ultra name a weibo
account started a new leak that claimed
that a future iPhone Ultra model will be
able to capture spatial photos and
videos for The Vision Pro headset that
can actually view them in real time
making them look realistic this would
basically require a 3D supporting camera
which means another main camera or an
upgraded lidar sensor and camera that's
super good to make at work and we do
actually have a leak about a new lighter
sensor coming this year to the 15 Pros
but I don't think that's going to be
enough to allow 3D video recording I do
however hope that Apple enables 8K video
recording this year to compete with
Samsung's 8K video which has gotten
really really good in past years but out
of all the new leaks and rumors for the
iPhone 15 Pro Models I'm the most
excited about the switch to the USBC
port and the much thinner bezels on the
front of the iPhone that's going to make
it feel more immersive I'm also really
excited for the lighter weight titanium
frame which will be much more
fingerprint resistant so you let me know
the feature that you are most excited
about down in the comment section below
and click the circle about to subscribe
so you don't miss out on our launch Day
videos and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
foreign